welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
this is a another edition of the
graduate
entry-level recruitment episode series
and i'm really excited today to be
joined by
james and lizzy and in the next 30
minutes we're going to be
talking about how they ended up in
recruitment the advice that they would
give to their younger sales if they were
just graduating again
advice they give to people that are on
the actual job mark at the moment or
maybe
graduating for the first time um and
we're gonna sort of find out why
we feel more people should be choosing
recruitment as a career
so before we go into this um lizzy i'm
gonna get you to introduce yourself
first and then james and then we'll
we'll get into it yeah hi so i'm lizzy
formisano i am a recruitment consultant
at mrs prime
and so i've been at this is prime for
about eight months now
i'm started as a resourcer and now a um
full 360 consultant
um tiny bit about this is prime so we
are a graduate sales recruitment company
and i specifically recruit graduates
into sales roles in london
awesome and james yeah hi um
i'm james solomon and i've been at
business program now for about 16 months
and that includes a placement here that
i did and
i sit on the region's desk at this is
prime so focusing primarily on
kind of any location outside of
manchester and london where our offices
are
and to do a lot of work in scotland
ireland the south west and america as
well
love that and then just for context then
so lizzy
you graduated in 2019
yeah yeah right and then james
you graduated this year right about
three weeks ago yeah
yeah i saw the old the classic pop in
champagne yeah
picture on linkedin so yeah congrats for
that so um
okay so let's start with you then james
like how like talk to us a bit about
how and like why you ended up sort of
committing or wanting to work in
recruitment after obviously graduating a
couple of weeks ago
yeah so obviously it started off as a as
just a placement yeah
and i say just a placement here because
i actually applied to do marketing at
prime
and so prime sponsored the the
manchester met football team and so
that's how i was aware of them
and i applied for a marketing position
and it was kind of had a couple of
interviews and
had a few conversations with neil who is
a co-founder in md in manchester
and kind of realized that i think what
i'm motivated by probably wasn't going
to be given to me through marketing
and and that was things like the clear
progression the commission for you know
for your hard work and things
and so i kind of had a bit of a decision
to make in terms of
did i want to try to try my hand at
recruitment and and i did
and i don't regret it and i thought at
the end of the day
it's you know a year of my life and
unfortunately it was cut slightly short
shoot to uh due to covid but
nine months of my life that i thought
you know what if it doesn't work out it
doesn't work out
um and i'm pleased to kind of say that
it did and so i went back into my final
year
quite refreshed knowing that i had a
little bit more direction now and
and then i say as of january this year
um was was asked to uh you know if i
wanted to come back so on a part-time
basis
and which i'm really really happy that i
did and and i say now
now back full time with this is prime so
yeah kind of uh
yeah it didn't really mean yeah yeah
fair enough so
and then just really quickly lizzy did
you did you not do a placement here
this is prime but did you also do a
placement here when i was at uni out of
interest
no no i actually didn't so i went
straight out of university into
a recruitment role actually i've got
quite a funny way of getting into
recruitment really and which we'll
probably go into later but yeah no i
didn't do a placement went straight into
recruitment after uni
really okay fair so let's um i want to
both just get
both your i guess honest thoughts uh
well i guess it'd be more james on like
yeah the benefits of potential placement
is but lizzy let's hear the the story
then on
how you got into recruitment and why
that's where you started your work
career outside of after leaving uni yeah
no so um i was i kind of you know as a
classic graduate you come out of
university you don't 100 know exactly
what you want to go into but i knew
exactly what my motivations were
and what my strengths were um absolutely
loved communicating i've been like in
hospitality my whole life so
love working with people using
interpersonal skills i wanted a career
where i could progress
really quickly um and obviously make
money to be honest and
to be quite frank have a really deep
learning potential um so recruitment
pretty much takes all those boxes so we
started off
um in a small recruitment firm that off
unfortunately got cut short just uh
due to cash flow issues and a redundancy
very early on but once i almost got a
taste for recruitment i was like
absolutely like
this is for me i really really love it
um went into internal recruitment role
and as i'm sure you can imagine
um when covered hit internal
recruitment's probably the worst place
you want to be
and so then that got cut short and
that's where oh wow yeah so that's when
i came across this is prime
um so still stuck with recruitment third
time lucky um
but yeah that was kind of the weird the
weird journey i suppose into it so
a couple hiccups on the way but um but
we're here now so uh
yeah a classic showcase of resilience
there
by you that's that's well fair play on
you to keep pushing on and
making that happen so i guess just
really quickly because i think it would
be
valuable for people i guess like one
james like how did you
how did you get a placement yeah out of
interest like how like how easy was it
to get one
and two like how should is that
something that people should be thinking
about
like what what are your thoughts on just
out of interest yeah i think um
sort of on that i think the first thing
i'd say is it's very difficult to get a
placement so you'll feel like you know
to anyone who is maybe applying or is
looking to apply next year
and you will feel like you're applying
to a lot i think i applied to around 28
if i'm being exact
and in terms of recommending it i think
the the kind of cliche is your lecturers
will kind of say
if you do a placement you know you're
more likely to get a first and things
like that
i can you know honestly say that i went
back to uni you know having just got up
at 6am for a whole year with a very
different mindset
and it does make you more mature it does
make you more switched on it does make
you more you know manage your time more
effectively
and and as well you know that the money
is obviously a massive bonus of that at
the time i probably wasn't thinking
about it too much
and but i'd say you know bonus exactly
yeah
and but it's difficult you've got to
you've really got to stick at it i think
in terms of applying to
placement opportunities yeah because i
can imagine it being super competitive
but it seems it seems like the benefits
it gave you was obviously added
bonus was like money but it gave you a
sense of sort of direction which a lot
of people struggle with
had a bit more of an idea of what work
might look like or what life might look
like out after
uni and as you said it gave you a sort
of um
an environment where you could i guess
yeah mature a bit and be around
people that yeah aren't in the uni
environment right because
yeah that's just a completely different
world absolutely compared to it yeah so
nice so um where i want to start then so
for you lizzy let me come to you on this
first like
so we're speaking about recruitment
quite positively but like what
what skills are experienced so you said
around progression and a potential
but like what what skills or experiences
recruitment giving you that you least
expected you think so far
um well i think it goes to show probably
based on my last answer the resilience
piece but i think that's such a classic
buzzword it gets thrown around
so much um in every kind of recruitment
interview or anything but i think
resilience is
a mad one not just in kind of what my
experience was like obviously going
having a couple hiccups along the way to
actually securing you know
what i want to do in the long term um
but actually in the role itself i think
a lot of people
before they get into recruitment don't
realize um how challenging it genuinely
is
um so i think the biggest thing that is
massively overlooked is because you are
working with people
there is always this you know an idea
that you have to kind of expect the
unexpected
people have their own mindsets they do
their own things so as much as you think
you have
as much control over a situation is as
you want
and at the end of the day you're still
working with another person with their
own opinion with their own mind and they
can do anything
and so i think definitely things not
going your way when you they genuinely
should or everything's in place and
things are going your way
and the ability to just pick yourself up
and and remain
really solutions focused and just
continue on and
thinking about what the end goal is
thinking about what you need to do to
rectify it that
um recruitment's definitely taught me
that because i've definitely had so many
situations where
you know you've said like a candidate's
not showing up to an interview last
minute or
maybe everything seems like it's going
your way and then someone pulls out of a
process or something and you just can't
focus on that you do have to just be so
solutions focused and so resilient to
get past that
so i definitely think that is probably
the biggest skill that um or trait even
though i
i've definitely learned over my career
particularly at prime and how is that
because because personally i think like
why i think one of the reasons why i
think
sort of recruitment should be seen as a
great career to go into is just because
like it does give you so much more than
like sales or whatever you think comes
with it in terms of like
how it can actually help you in your
life so i guess you mentioned that it's
a lot more of a mindset piece which i
absolutely love but like how is that
curious like how is that manifested in
like lizzy outside of work for like
like actual lizzie the human being like
how is it like what being the positive
do you feel like as well on that
yeah no fair enough i think it it gives
you so to be honest it gives you such
a much more positive outlook on
everything you you really
genuinely back yourself so much more in
any part of your life so if you
like if something bad happens to me now
if i i'm hit with a situation where i
have to
overcome an obstacle um the mindset that
recruitment's given me and like being
solutions focus being resilient
genuinely just
you know being positive and optimistic
about things um
like recruitment has massively impacted
me in that so now if i go into any
situation i can just be
i'm so much more confident going into
any situation so much more
you know positive about any situation
because i know like
i've faced so many challenges in my job
role that you know outside of work it
doesn't it doesn't really seem
as bad to be fair yeah i love that yeah
that's awesome
i think that's so that's like so useful
and i just feel like more and more young
people need that because i feel like
there's just so there can be so much
more weight attached with like getting
the perfect grades having the perfect
grin all these types of things so
actually
dealing with adversity things not going
your own way is only going to help you
in
all different areas of your life isn't
it if you're sort of willing to look at
it and go right what could have done
differently or
right tomorrow's a new day etc um so
what about a few james what sort of
comes up for you like what have you
taken from recruitment so far that you
least expected
i think in terms of kind of placement
year-wise
the one sort of and he said before kind
of experience that i think recruitment
has given me is
being able to kind of i guess put myself
in an environment and socialize with
the founders the co-founders the manage
directors of all these sort of clients
that the prime work with
and yeah as a placement student that was
so weird for me kind of hearing what all
my my
mates were doing in their work it was
kind of nine to five and it was that and
then you go home and that's it
and i was kind of you know going out
with these clients and you know meeting
with you know
having just normal conversations you
know at the end of it well i think
obviously we are very social people in
recruitment but you know having just
normal conversations with business
owners and managing directors that from
placement year was quite a bit of a
strange experience because i didn't kind
of expect it
and yeah in terms of i think kind of
transferring into everyday life i'd
probably say
touching a little bit on what lizzy said
kind of i'm a lot less stressed about
things that
just are a lot less important now and
and i think i love that
i'm quite unorganized and quite uh i'd
say probably quite a stressy person
anyway
and and i think one thing recruitment
has has definitely given me is being
able to kind of look at things and be
like right
take a step back is it absolutely not
not much of a big deal like
you know i still get stressed about the
little things i won't deny that but a
few things you know i think that's
the main thing you know you have to kind
of prioritize not only sort of tasks but
also what's worth kind of committing a
lot of mental time to as well
yeah love that so i guess what i want to
find out from both of you now then so
obviously because i'm sure you
communicate this to the sort of people
that you speak to about
um recruitment which is obviously this
whole first year recruitment right
which is sort of typically described
like it'll be the hardest year of your
life
you're gonna face so many different
challenges all these types of things so
i guess
like for you james i know obviously it's
been sort of a part one and a part two
now
and part two is gonna be like you full
time cracking on et cetera but like
if we're to put sort of all your
experiences so far together your
placement and
where you are now yeah i guess what have
been
like some of your biggest challenges
then so far that you've had to sort of
work through just to paint
a real picture of like what people can
expect and some of the challenges that
they
might expect like what have been one
some of the biggest challenges you've
had to work through and
how have you been working through them
so far yeah i think
um it kind of goes back to what lizzie
said in terms of people are going to do
their own thing
and i came into recruitment very much
a social kind of guy you know i'm happy
to be the center of attention
i feel like i can talk to anyone but
that's that's only going to kind of get
you so far
and you know picking up the phone is
obviously the first the first sort of
hurdle
and then once you've done that there's
only so much you can really control and
so it for me a little bit it was the
kind of constant rejection which i don't
think i was used to because i've never
you know i worked in a restaurant before
this so people came to me to eat food
you know it wasn't yeah i didn't have to
sell anything
so i think the the rejection for me was
a little bit tough because it kind of
probably not my ego a little bit
admittedly and and as well i think
on that the problem was i was very
nervous in terms of kind of getting on
the phone straight away so i kind of
hide in the corner or i'd kind of move
away from my desk so i wasn't actually
getting anything what are you nervous
about
i don't know you don't want to say the
wrong thing and looking back
i feel you know i feel a bit silly but i
don't know i just think
you know it's that risk i think of
getting rejected you know what as if
they do say no
you're kind of on the spot and you don't
know what to say and that for me was the
biggest the biggest challenge and you
know
that not only sort of occurs on a phone
but also when you've got people booked
in for an interview or you know
for a prime training day or whatever it
is and they cancel or that you know they
don't come and
it's just that sort of constant kind of
repeat rejection for me early on which
was which was tough now i'm i'm
obviously controlling it earlier on so
it's i'm putting more responsibility on
me
um in terms of the control piece so it
happens less which is good
and but yeah that rejection really
really kind of knocked my ego a little
bit i think
yeah yeah i definitely yeah i would say
that was one of the biggest things for
me because people didn't
people didn't tell me that that would be
involved like how much rejection you
would get
and it doesn't it doesn't look like
every time you pick up the phone
someone's going to tell you to like
effort
that isn't that doesn't happen it might
happen every now and again but
it's just like you said it's being told
no and it's like
being pushed back and these sorts of
things but that's um
it's just really valuable to be in those
situations and get comfortable with them
so i guess lizzy for you then what
obviously besides
being made redundant or being in a
difficult situation of
the first two times you had to work
through that i guess maybe
if you could talk maybe about primal you
could batch it all together like what
what have been some of the challenges
that you've had to work through or
we can talk about you think yeah yeah
well i think this is
to be honest this goes without saying
this is more i suppose a bit of advice
um i'd say but the biggest challenge is
like understanding how
hard the role is and how much effort you
have to put into it so
and we always talk to all of our
accounts obviously we recruit in sales
and so it's very similar in terms of
it's
it's hard work and i think what
potentially if you're
not 100 about recruitment or you go in
without knowing exactly what you're
getting yourself in for
um you don't understand the amount of
work ethic that is required to be
successful so i definitely say like
the biggest challenge is really
understanding like you're going to have
to put in the hours
you see these ot's getting recruitment
you see the quick progression that you
can get
genuinely you can't just go clock in
clock out do the bare minimum and
achieve that you have to put in
so much for it so i think treating
recruitment as a career and not a job
that is the biggest the first thing 100
to understand and overcome straight away
off the bat
um similar to kind of what james was
actually saying getting on the phone
early i'm 100
think that if you can just get rid of
that fear straight away
you're the whole role is on the phone
pretty much especially at the start so
just
get it over with and then genuinely it's
it's so much
although so and it can be really
daunting to obviously
can talk about it what went well what
didn't go well what can you do next time
um i think the one really key thing
actually um because a lot of the time
when i was
um first starting in recruitment when
you get off the phone with someone and
sometimes maybe your manager might ask
okay did you find out this you're like
oh i didn't even ask that question so
asking really really good questions and
knowing like what you're missing i think
it's so so crucial so
definitely think like the biggest
challenge is understanding how hard it
is and that
just being willing to put in hours
putting the work getting on the phones
and then just
asking really really good questions on
that and being inquisitive like having
a really continuous improvement mindset
i suppose wanting to actually learn and
improve
um so not being afraid to do calls in
front of other people because it is
genuinely the best way
that you learn i'd say yeah yeah for
sure i love that
so just really quickly like on this on
the work ethic piece
it's like lizzy what on average like
what what
like how long are your days on average
like let's just paint a real picture
here it's like is it
like eight till six like what we talking
i know it will vary but on average what
would you say
yeah well cool i was eight till six um
but to be honest with you like you have
to be flexible so for example yesterday
i was prepping a guy at 7 45
pm just because he works all day um but
he's a great candidate and i wanted to
do it so
um yeah you do it's eight to six core
but you just
that is you have to be flexible with
that you have to understand that you
sometimes do have to put in a bit more
um and obviously the thing is with that
like what i don't describe recruitment
as it's high reward but you just have to
work for it so
if you are aren't afraid to work long
hours and if you are willing to do it
then
that's absolutely fine i think the
biggest thing though despite it being
those long hours is that
you genuine it's so much fun and i don't
want to kind of miss sell it as just you
go in and you're just working
absolutely yeah of course yeah so far my
time yeah but you are having
so much fun um so but yeah it is it that
is long hours like yeah
is that g and is that how you is that
like i know every business is different
but like typically what on average
across the board
that's what it typically looks like or
yeah i'd probably say
typically in recruitment yeah you will
be expecting that like eight to six i
mean some
sometimes it differs eight thirty to six
typically you can be expecting those
hours i reckon okay
cool so and james would you share that
as well in like the places outside of
london manchester i know some places
will vary but just to paint a real
picture of like work ethic and
working hard like what does that
actually look like i think obviously
the level of work ethics needed but i
think it's important
to remember kind of why you're doing it
well first of all you're working in a
role that is
only involving people essentially so you
kind of have to accept that you're
always going to be working on someone
else's schedule and someone else's
calendar
so that's the first thing and i think
the other thing is it's also kind of
why are you doing it so you know you're
not doing lizzy's not prepping a
candidate at 7 45 because she wants to
be better to get you know it's
it's more than that i think and you know
i think that's why
the kind of motivations obviously here a
lot is is really important so
i think as long as those two things are
kind of understood i think that's
probably the main
the main thing i would add on that and
but you know
the main point being you're in a role
where you're working around people so
you kind of have to accept that that
potentially might be part of the role
you know other people work other people
have commitments
um and your job is to kind of facilitate
that i guess
sure so but before we go into like i
want to get sort of advice from
both of you on like interview tips and
these types of things but really quickly
james if you could just talk a bit about
this because you mentioned it and i know
this is something that
we spoke about that both you really
wanted to talk about because you speak
to a lot of your
sort of graduate entry-level people
about it is that motivation
so i guess what so if i'm listen to this
and i'm considering recruitment on early
on
in my journey like i guess both you said
it's around like understanding
why you're doing it i guess and to
remain motivated yeah so what what does
that
like i don't know i guess like talk a
bit about that is it that i need to be
really clear on like have some really
clear goals
could be financial goals could be other
personal goals or could be i don't know
wanna
buy something or whatever like what what
are you typically talking to people
about and why is this important do you
think
i think well for me the one thing that i
always kind of phrase as when i'm
speaking to candidates is
you need to be motivated by the things
that you can get out of recruitment
so whatever it could be that's then what
has to you know that's probably going to
be the right motivation for you so don't
kind of choose your motivation
based on recruitment if what you can get
out of recruitment whether that be
progression
commission you know satisfaction
obviously working with you know placing
people into roles whatever it might be
that's then what the motivator should be
and you don't need to be motivated by
all of them
and for me now progression's probably my
my biggest motivation
and you know i think my sort of
demographic we jump on trends we jump
off trends we get bored you know we want
constant progression
and and for me that's that's the biggest
thing at the moment
um but i think sometimes people kind of
think you know they need to choose their
motivations to align with recruitment
you can literally just google you know
what what can what are the incentives in
recruitment what can a career in
recruitment offer me
and if you find that you kind of match
up to them then you know potentially
recruitment is
the career of choice hence kind of what
i did with you know with my placement
i wanted ideally marketing was i going
to get
quick progression commission out of
marketing probably not and i found that
in recruitment and now i love it
and yeah so i think that's probably the
main the main kind of thing i would say
is
look what recruitment can offer you and
if you think it matches what you're
motivated by then you know
potentially it is the right career for
you yeah nice i feel like these things
can change can't they but we're
sort of want to highlight if you're
putting in the work then you need to
have some
motivators because there's just way way
more easier jobs that you can do that
don't require you prepping candidates
according to eight you know i mean it's
too hard not to be too hard yeah exactly
so cool so let's let's go into
sort of advice then and things that
you've learned maybe or the sort of
advice that you give now so
i guess lizzy for you then obviously
james mentioned around how competitive
it is to get a placement i'm sure it's
just as competitive
for like entry-level roles or graduate
roles
so like i guess firstly like what would
be your maybe like
number one tip or two top tips for
people
that can i guess help them stand out in
the interview process or at least give
them the best possible chance of
getting interviewed or getting seen and
because i'm sure it is really
competitive so like what comes up for
you there for people
listening on that yeah yeah absolutely i
think my
best advice probably would be utilize
linkedin um
i always go on about this all over my
linkedin but i'm a massive advocate for
it i think that
and particularly in the market i'm right
now like me and james probably speak to
a ridiculous amount of candidates on a
day-to-day basis
and it is hard to stand up but when if
you apply to a role if you then find out
who the recruiter is from the hiring
manager
connect with them on linkedin message
them utilize your network because
it really makes you stand out it shows
that you're so committed to getting the
role so i definitely think
like any graduate wanting to get into it
get make sure you've got linkedin first
of all make sure that you actually use
it so that's
connect with people in the industry that
you want to get into to connect with
you know people in recruitment that you
want to get into that you can genuinely
learn from
um when you apply to us connect with
people straight away message them
tell them that you've applied tell them
why why you're interested in it
um you know just utilize that because
linkedin is not only a great place to
get noticed
and through those methods but you can
learn so much from it and that kind of
leads on to my second point but
i'd always say do more and so if you
think about like the average person
applying for a role they probably
make a cv apply for the role and then
fingers
crossed fingers and hope that they get a
response um do anything that you can
outside of that so that's
not just kind of trying to get noticed
on linkedin but it's also doing other
things like really
reading up on the industry making sure
that you're fully immersing yourself in
your job search
and reading books listening to podcasts
like this anything really that can
enhance your skill set because
the more you go in prepared then when
you do an interview the more
understanding that you've got of the
role or the career path that you want to
get into
um you just come across so much more
credible and so much more committed to
getting into it so that would be my
thing i'd definitely say use linkedin
genuinely utilize it and and do more
than than the average person applying
for a role
yeah yeah because it is weird isn't it i
mean i didn't go to university but when
i
like my perception of linkedin was like
you go in there to get a job
that's it basically but like i think
especially if you
if you find that maybe going into like
yeah tech sales or
i've just lost lizzie but herman yeah
she'll come back but i guess what i was
gonna say was like
particularly like this if you end up
sort of looking at sales opportunities
james like
yeah like there's what a better way to
showcase what you're about by like
showing like you're doing that with your
job search you know what i mean like if
i'm popping up in your
dms and going hey like you may have seen
my application i know you're busy but
they do like you're showing that you're
following up
you're being proactive and these are the
types of things that
you might end up doing when you actually
land the job and
so yeah i guess yeah get your two tips
but feel free to add on
to what lizzy said yeah well i was gonna
say like if you call called a candidate
and all they saw was the phone number on
their phone you know
it's 50 50 whether you answer it because
it's just a phone call so
if you're creative with your kind of
outreach and you send them like you say
you know quirky message on linkedin
like they could do to you you know it
works both ways you draw attention
and i think you know in terms of in
terms of kind of things that
i think i'm doing uh quite big at the
moment in terms of kind of just
messaging candidates on linkedin i think
the fact you can make it personal
straight away and you know sometimes
even without a phone call you know just
go straight in with a message look i've
received your application i come
straight to your linkedin profile
because i can't because it's you know
easily accessible let's book a call and
i think it's just about you know and it
works both ways you know we have to be
creative with with our outreach
obviously
i'm sure a lot of people would have seen
lizzie's lizzie's videos on linkedin but
i know she gets a lot of you know a lot
of attraction through them because she's
being creative
and so there is no reason why you know
candidates shouldn't do the same thing
and apply that to your job search yeah
absolutely
what would your top tip then be for
people to stand out get noticed get that
interview
it's the for me personally it's the
follow-up and
so make the application bare minimum and
then
what are you doing after that to
separate your application from
you know in some cases hundreds of
others you know in terms of the roles
that we recruit
linkedin you know even kind of you know
viewing my profile on linkedin
and i know if i've seen the application
in my inbox and i've got a few calls to
make before and then they view my
profile
i'm automatically more inclined to think
right they're switched on you know
they're looking yeah
and things like that so just just think
about kind of what you
make the application and then what's
that kind of first step to really grab
attention
um after that and simple as simple as
viewing viewing a profile on linkedin is
probably the easiest and the most
quickest way to grab attention off a
recruiter for sure
yeah so like yeah so be organized maybe
like you wanted to keep track of these
things
yeah every time as i'm sure both of you
learning like the money's in the
follow-up
in recruiting yeah like that's that's
where you're not always going to get
through to like
the person you want to in that first
time um it's always like i mean in my
first year recruitment my nickname in
the office was like he's from the
hounder which is a bit savage but
i would just i was like right well i
know i'm back myself that when we do
speak but i'm going to make it a good
experience but
yeah you just got you just got to keep
at it and you've got like you've got to
approach that with your job sir
surely do you know what i mean yeah um
and it will get noticed
um of course so lizzie good to have you
back that's all all
good but basically what i wanted to um i
think she might frozen actually
that's fine yeah james let me come to
you then so i guess
so you've spoken about how sort of grads
can get noticed
i guess like why don't we then get
like okay so i've done that i've
followed up i've stood out i've been
creative
what about like your top tips for me
actual interview
would you say like what are the common
things that maybe sort of
entry level or grads typically go wrong
where you sort of
typically help people make sure that
they don't make those sort of um
mistakes a lot of people make like what
comes up through there maybe like top
one to
three tips on interview side of things i
think the first thing i'd say
is you're not expected to have
experience
direct experience as a grad you'll
you'll you will hear horror stories of
you know
going through five interviews and then
got told yeah these like
these not academy things are like the
little um assessments where you're like
yeah you're pitching in front of like
loads of like yeah okay
sometimes i think in terms of that it
might be more maybe the the company
you're applying for than actually
yourself but
yeah i think as a grad the most
attractive things that you know and i'm
speaking pretty much as one and the most
attractive thing that i think we have is
we're we're extremely driven
and extremely keen to learn so that
that's got to be the first thing you
know you're coming from a background
like myself let's say hospitality you
don't know recruitment but you've got
the right sort of soft skill set to do
recruitment
and so i think the first thing is
definitely kind of get across that
you've got a foundation you know you've
got transferable skills now you want to
apply that and obviously then grow in
recruitment
and i think the other one is definitely
motivations
that's got to be you know massive um
what do we what do i what is it has it
got to be more than like i want this job
because i want to
want money like what what are you sort
of coaching these grads to like
think about communicate i don't think
i don't think it does need to be so well
it can be but i don't think it always
does you know it's
it's attractive to a hiring you know if
you're running a business where the
targets are rewarded by progression
or commission you know it's it's kind of
attractive for a hiring manager to hear
just to let you know i'm gonna do
everything i can to earn commission
because how did you earn the commission
you hit your targets
so it's kind of like a two-way thing you
know the the candidate is getting
rewarded with what they're looking for
the commission
and then obviously the hiring manager is
obviously growing his company because
the staff
are you know growing their company sorry
because the staff are hitting targets
and so i don't think it always needs to
be deeper than progression or deeper
than commission
the main thing i'd say on that though is
you need to have reasons you know
everyone in the world can say they're
motivated by money but why are they
actually motivated you know what do they
want to buy
in in a month two months two years three
years um
excuse me yeah anchored someone sorry
yeah good example
i was going to say a good example we had
recently at one of our one of our
training days at prime was
we had a candidate who said he was
really motivated by money and
the long-term goal is to have a house
that in the kitchen has an island
it's an island in the middle of the
kitchen so really specific yeah so
and it sounds kind of you know you might
think why are you thinking that far
ahead but that's the sort of person that
will
will really work hard because they have
you know 10-year plans i actually like
have thought a bit about like what they
were yeah exactly yeah
and you know it can be as little as you
know it's my you know i want to go
honestly
i want to go on a summer holiday after
you know after the pandemic and sort of
everything's about to know i want to go
on a summer holiday
you know that's a short-term goal and
people who know exactly what they want
to spend their money on
are more likely to to go and get it i
think if you if you're there just to
earn money to
to live comfortably is quite a common
one what does that really look like you
know how much money do you actually need
to do that and yeah yeah that'll be my
main thing on the on the motivations is
having
kind of actual examples as to why you
want to go and get it
yeah no worries absolutely i've got two
final questions for you basically
yeah so before i ask you to get your
honest thoughts on like why
you believe more people should consider
recruitment as an actual career choice
not just an accident
i just want to get obviously like you
said graduated this year
like a lot of recruitment businesses
want to
hire people like you right your age
group etc
so what i want to find out from you and
you can talk about from your own
perspective and also
like just your friends and just
obviously speaking to graduates
um day in day out yeah what type of
recruitment business do these people
actually want to work for i mean like
what actual benefits
excite them what actual benefits like
make them like really excited about
working for a particular company why
actually resonates with them because i
think
it's just so easy to go down the cliche
route of like right we're gonna
get you trips to ibiza you can get the
rolex you've got the money all this but
like what
in you like what is it that people want
your age and below what people coming
through do you think
i i'll i'll stand by the point of
we will get bored quickly in my but in
terms of in terms of kind of
having a having a long-term plan as i
said you know
we jump on you know myself included you
jump on trends you know
to whether it's a tick-tock trend
instagram whatever it is um
you know i think it's natural to get
bored it's probably a good thing you
know you want to be progressing
and you know you'll be in you know an
entry-level role for six months you'll
want to progress to the next level you
want to kind of keep moving on
and she's back again and yeah but no i
think
i think the main thing is probably just
that drive
is you know the progression i think and
i can't speak on behalf of you know
every graduate
and my sure but i think the main thing
that has to be on offer is the
progression
because with the progression comes all
the other incentives you know it comes
with
the lunch club so when we so when we say
progression right like what does that
actually like what like
what we like what does what does that
actually mean like what do they want is
it
they want they want to be able to tell
their mates that they're a manager is it
they want to manage
lead people they want to help a lot what
what actually is it i know it will be
different for different people but
typically
what is it that they want out of
progression because it's just a it can
cover a lot of things can't there
yeah i think i said i don't know if
lizzy wants to add on to this because i
know she's back and forth
no i think that the main thing for me on
that point would be
tailored progression and tailored
progression yeah so
have a progression plan that's
absolutely you know have a have a
straight line to director level
but have different kind of branches off
of that you know what what are you going
to do
for someone when they get to like you
say a management position but they don't
want to manage people
okay well could they manage something
else you know could they manage you know
tailor the progression i think would be
the main thing not everyone's going to
be attracted to the same role not
everyone's going to you know want the
same role
and there are obviously different kind
of routes more sort of the bd side or
more the you know
the people management side but i think
the main thing on that would be
having tailored progression you know
what are people good at what
what is this person's strengths how can
we make a role or how can we kind of
you know tweak the role a little bit to
work to their strengths and in their
favor
um yeah okay i think so just yeah just
making sure that
like you you always make him feel like
this entry-level talent
is moving forward basically yeah and
you're pushing for new things cool
so lizzy good to have you back we're all
good
so basically the last two questions i
have the one i just asked which i'd love
your thoughts on
is basically what i want to know from
your perspective
obviously there's so there'll be
countless recruitment businesses that
want to
attract people like both of you and
obviously the the graduates and
entry-level talent
who speaks on a day-to-day basis but i
just wanted to hear like your honest
thoughts on like what
do people like you your age group or et
cetera like
what do they actually want from their
employers like what actually excites
them about recruitment business
because like yeah it's easy just to
shout about the
the cliche incentives you know like the
money i b for trips all this but like
what like obviously james went to
progression but
then if you wanted to add anything like
why is it that these people actually
driven by like what is it that they want
out of their employers
yeah sure i actually um it's funny you
say that because i recently did a
posting on linkedin about
company culture and it's similar to what
you're saying now a lot of people think
that
you know grads just look at companies
and they think oh perfect like bean bags
and ping pong tables that's exactly what
i want out of my
of my recruitment career but it's not i
think similar like to add on to what
james is saying 100 think progression
is so important i think and graduates
want to see that they're not going to be
stagnant they want to see that they
whatever they do in their career now is
genuinely going to add up to
to build out a genuine long-term career
so i think never being stagnant and
always moving up is something
really really important and it's also
really motivating and i think also being
in an environment where you genuinely
think not just for your professional
growth but your personal growth as well
so i think being in an environment that
fosters
like progression and development so and
by that i mean a really good
training program where you're not just
kind of thrown into the deep end giving
a phone
and some numbers in a database like go
and make some calls and make some
placements like you're genuinely going
to be
um trained up and given all the support
and all the resources that you need to
be successful
so i think a really clear training plan
and development plan
um is so so crucial particularly in
recruitment where it is so difficult and
genuinely when people do say like it's
the hardest six months the first six
months the hardest six months of your
life
it genuinely can be if you don't have
the support so i think
somewhere that gives you support and
like foster's high progression and high
growth
um is so crucial so i definitely think
being started off on the right foot um
is
is 100 what people look for and then
with that comes that progression with
that comes our own potential but i think
yeah starting off the right foot hundred
percent yeah nice
yes it's a so businesses need to really
make sure they've got a clear
progression plan and
that can be just in so many different
ways can't it so i think that's
i feel like sometimes that's where
smaller grown recruitment businesses can
miss a trick
because they feel like they're not big
enough to offer progression but there's
so many different ways that you can
offer that isn't there and
promote people in different ways and
these things so okay cool so look the
last question to wrap up them lizzy i'll
come back to you
so what so i want to find out from both
of you firstly so obviously we always
hear
recruit people fall into recruitment as
an accident right um i do feel like
that sort of needle is definitely
changing a bit um i was in the small
percentage of people that generally just
i wanted to get into recruitment because
i wanted to become a better more
all-rounded salesperson coming from a
transactional insurance sales background
so like one
lizzie are you finding more people that
you speak to are going lisa i actually
want to get into recruitment
just interested here for honest thoughts
on that and then two
um i just want you to share like why you
feel
more people more graduate entry-level
talent should be considering
recruiting as a career choice not just
an accident
rather yeah um i definitely do think
actually people are um
more interested in getting into
recruitment as a crib because i suppose
what my perception of is i think people
are starting to understand really that
recruit there is there shouldn't be this
like negative perception of recruitment
where
you are just kind of a salesperson just
pushing people into roles and things
like that i think a lot of
people are starting to realize it is you
know a lot more challenging than that
there's a lot more to it and
and you can have you know massive impact
on on your career as well as someone
else so
i think i've definitely seen i think a
lot more people are interested in in
recruitment as a career of choice
in terms of why people should consider
it more of it as a career of choice
rather than i suppose this perception of
falling into it because i definitely
think there is that
idea of people do fall into recruitment
i think particularly because the barrier
for entry like
but it seems to be a little bit lower
potentially than other um
industries where you know you don't
necessarily there's not a degree in
recruitment there's not
any specific skills that you need to get
into it as long as you
like have that drive you can so i think
um there is that kind of preconception
where i don't know what else i'll do
i'll just do recruitment and see if that
if that works out
and the people should genuinely see it
as a career of choice because
like similar to what me and james have
been talking about there's so much
progression in it it's not just a job
you can genuinely it's i don't think
i've seen any other kind of career path
where you can start right from the
bottom
and then get promoted so like twice in a
year like less than that
really really quickly down to your work
as well yeah completely down to you
that's the thing
exactly completely down to your merit
it's not just okay private lizzy's been
working here for five years now i think
she's do a promotion it's like oh my god
lizzy smashing all the targets but james
smashed all his targets
um yeah like he's his promotion target
so
it's not there's no other career where
genuinely down to your work and down to
your merit you can just progress and go
as far as you want to go so there's no
kind of limit there
and and also to work in environment that
is so fast-paced it's so fun
um you know the earning potential is
there as well again like it goes with
that theme of this
no limit and i just i couldn't imagine
being in any other kind of career where
you just aren't capped at all you can
just
work really really hard and get so much
out of it so people need to realize that
if you want a career where your hard
work genuinely pays off
um recruitment is the one for you yeah
like
when i had no idea what i wanted to do
and then landed my first sales job i was
like oh my god like
why would i ever work in a job where i
could put all my all into it and the
person next to me
could just like half-ass it and we get
paid the same there's just no way that
i'm ever going to be
in that top environment again yeah um
okay love that
and then james for you why like one do
you feel like
have you have you been hearing more
people go oh i actually want to get into
it or
i've been interested in that and two
yeah why do you feel
more people should consider it as a
career choice i think definitely yeah
even from when i started placement i'd
say i'm speaking to more people that are
saying
you know okay so the first question i
might ask you know what roles are you
applying for you know
specifically recruitment they know
exactly why they want recruitment i
think that comes from
you know the sort of work you're doing
what you know what lizzy's doing on
linkedin you know people are a little
probably probably more educated on it
now
uh yeah i'll be completely honest i had
no i wasn't big on
yeah i didn't say big on i didn't use
linkedin a lot before placement here i
didn't really go on it i didn't know the
recruitment scene
and you need to actually need to change
that by the way they need yeah no i
agree
i mean yeah i i i was i think i'd done
like one post on my linkedin and that
was when i got my gold dmv and i put
like a selfie on there and that was
literally it
and but i think like you say now i think
more and more people are inclined to go
on linkedin and i think that's through
placement for example you know me doing
a placement in in recruitment
i was telling all my mates you know i'll
look at my linkedin post i've just said
it you know yeah
and people kind of gradually gradually
use it and
but i think i think yes definitely
people are now more choosing it as
career of choice because i think
it's now just become you know everyone
in recruitment is saying you know why
would you not choose it and there isn't
no one's actually coming up with i'm
seeing a lot of reasons to choose i'm
not really seeing many reasons as to why
to not choose it
you know if you're motivated by by
progression by money you know by working
in a fast-paced environment
you will get that in recruitment so you
will choose to work in recruitment and
i think in terms of kind of just remind
me what the the second part of that of
that question is
no you pretty much it was more about
like why people should consider it as a
career i mean i could obviously you know
echo everything that lizzie said the
main thing i would say
in terms of grads is it's kind of like
you know imagine working for three years
at uni
you know working all day every day and
getting you know or you know failing
you'd be gutted you know you work hard
to get good results to get you know to
get it first at the end of your three
years
you work hard in recruitment it's
exactly the same you know you work hard
you'll hit your targets you'll get
promoted
and it really is as simple as that
there's no discrimination in terms of
when you've joined or you know how long
you've been there or you know someone
else is going to get promoted at the
same time it is literally
if you're working hard you will see the
results you know there is
i i find it hard to believe there's any
business that probably doesn't reward
you know in recruitment that doesn't
reward targets like that
yeah fair right i know i said that was
my last question but i'm gonna ask you
both one more
okay so lizzy i'll come to you first i
want you to share your top
two tips on how to survive
obviously i know you're still going for
this but how to survive and
thrive people's that first year in
recruitment or first six months in
recruitment
okay um i suppose don't know what i'd
say
work really hard just get your head down
and work for it um
no one is gonna make you do things the
way i always look at it is if i
every time i pick up my phone or every
time i open my laptop i can literally
make money or i can literally progress
or hit my targets no one's really gonna
tell you to do that so you need to have
that drive and that work ethic to do it
so that'll be
my first thing just work really hard
what
do it and you'll see results 100 percent
um second tip i'd probably say is
um just be solutions focused as well so
similar to what i kind of said at the
beginning um
actually don't get knocked back too much
by things that happen
just accept that you know you're in a
role where you know you are going to
face challenges you are going to hit
loads of obstacles just accept that
early on so then when
you do actually hit the obstacles and
meet the challenges and you can just be
solutions focused focus on what you
actually need to achieve and what you
can do to rectify that
to then go and overcome that so that
would be it work hard and be solutions
focused
james sent you top two tips to survive
and smash those
first six months yeah i'd say don't be
afraid to make mistakes
um it is gent you know as lizzy said
there's no degree in recruitment
rarely have people done recruitment
before graduating whether it's you know
like a placement here i am seeing that a
little bit more now
and don't be afraid to make mistakes and
want to make mistakes in front of other
people or you genuinely will not get any
feedback
and i probably learned that the hard way
but you know now i'm you know more than
happy to kind of
even now you know i set up my line
manager kyler i know obviously
you know quite well and even now he'll
still say you know oh
this is a call you haven't done before
you know do it in front of me you know
stay in your seat and do it
um i think actually we all kind of like
to walk around and stuff but you know
even
even 16 months into the role you know he
still wants me to be in front of him so
he can kind of coach me
and that leads on to the second one so
the first one is make mistakes and the
second one is be
be coachable um you know except that
you're going to have the soft skills you
know a lot of people will have the soft
skills for recruitment you know whether
from
hospitality or retail or whatever
they've done but
you know be prepared now that you've got
to kind of take all those soft skills
and learn a lot more in terms of not
only you know
kind of about yourself but also about
the industry you know how it works and
stuff
be prepared to you know to be molded
into a little bit you know well
not molded yourself but be prepared to
be coached you know from i suppose the
soft skills level to you know a b2b
kind of recruiter level and yeah you
know take on advice make the mistakes
and
and suppose those two have to work
really closely together i think if you
do one without the other then you know
you'll probably find you won't grow as
quickly
and so don't be afraid to make mistakes
and you know be coachable when you are
getting feedback on the mistakes you've
made
nice yeah i think i would just add
looking but look i would just add like
you should you got to be someone that
like takes responsibility
like the quicker you like stop pointing
the finger and going ah
like that hasn't worked because of this
or whatever like the better basically so
like
yeah all the things that you said and
then just be willing to take full
responsibility of like
things going wrong not going so well
um instead of being in like a victim
mindset
um lizzie james been a pleasure
thank you so much for uh coming on
sharing excited to see how
uh both your careers evolve and um yeah
big thanks for
being involved in this series so thank
you appreciate it thank you very